foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships we're here to talk
about your life and your money I'm
joined by my co-host John deloney
sitting to my right give us a call today
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll talk about
whatever's on your heart whatever's on
your mind if as it relates to money and
your relationships let's go to Columbia
South Carolina we got Lindsay on the
line what's going on Lindsay
Hi how are you we're doing good how are
you
I'm great thank you for asking you're
welcome
how can I help today
so um a brief rundown about what's going
on is that I
sold my shares in partnership in my
business sold my house and came to
Columbia with my husband so we could
live here in his hometown and start our
life here and we went to buy some land
to build our Dream House on
and we found out the day that we was
closing on our land that
his mother had actually stolen his
inheritance account and he was unable to
purchase the land and this has just put
a string of financial hardships on us
since we found this out how did she
steal how did she do that if his
if his name was on the the inherited
account
um he did allow her access for the
account just so she could put money into
the account when he needed her to do so
for his errands to help that but um is
she in jail
no why I wish why didn't you call the
police somebody sold more than a quarter
of a million dollars from you and your
husband
that is very true but he is very
forgiving and I'm forgiving too but I
also have a responsibility to make sure
me and my wife eat
that is very true but and we're not
talking about chump change we're talking
about
three hundred thousand dollars that's
what my screen says she cashed in her
mom card when she decided to steal from
her son and his wife
he taxes and we're having to move back
to Kentucky and thankfully
the business I was partnered in and had
cheers in is allowing me to reinstate
all that and I can start work again soon
but that's all great what you're saying
I'm sorry to cut you off what you're
saying is great I'm glad that things are
kind of going on the up and up with your
job and that there's some great things
happening but that's not the solution
to what's taking place with your
mother-in-law and I don't want you to
think that you're having to move back
because you didn't prosecute the person
who stole the money from you and seek uh
uh getting re repaid
I I agree but um
you know things they're just really hard
and we're having to sell all of our
property here in South Carolina no no no
no hold on you got to change your
language
because you are choosing to not hold the
person accountable who stole from you
you are thus choosing to sell everything
leave that state and go start life
somewhere else
no nobody's forcing you to do anything
you were making all of these choices
correct
so what what question do you have for us
um I'm having a hard time with my
husband
um yeah I would be too
he's very forgiving and even though no
he's a coward yeah I don't think that's
forgiving I don't think that I'm gonna
call that
attribute forgiveness he's a coward I I
would forgive too
even though she's done all this and we
've healed from us to this day we he
wants to continue financially and
support her
after we move yeah but you're not going
to do that
you're not going to do that that's what
I try to convince him but it seems he
wants to because he's you know an only
child and she realized right all right
we gotta we gotta
I'm not in the business of telling
people to
that their marriage is over that well
that's not true I've told people that
but I was gonna say you have told people
that John
um I'm not in the business of telling
people they need to get divorced
I want you to I but I am in the business
of telling the truth here's the deal
behavior is a language
what your husband is telling you loud
and clear using no words at all
that he will force his wife to go to
work so that he can provide
um food and shelter for someone who
stole everything from his family
he would rather keep a thief
um
he would rather keep a thief having
living standards above that of his wife
and I take a much broader view I've said
this on the show before I take a much
broader view of of fidelity we're
obsessed with marital Fidelity when it
comes to sexuality but we we've
completely throw it out when it comes to
financial Fidelity emotional Fidelity to
psychological safety we just get rid of
all that so when it comes to cheating on
your husband is cheating on you with his
mom not in a sexual gross way but in a
whose needs come first way
and until you stop using language like
well we're having to do this or how and
you step back and say I am worth more
than this
and I married him you you you told him
um all mine is yours and all yours is
mine till death do us part and he told
you that too and he's going back on on
what he said
and until you choose to decide that
you're worth more than what you're doing
you're just gonna end up back in
Kentucky working full-time doing your
thing and sending part of your paycheck
to your husband I mean part of your
paycheck to your mother-in-law who stole
from you
Lindsay have you guys ever done any kind
of counseling
any any marriage counseling
no we haven't but this is our only issue
that we've had um
no it's not it can't be
um if you were to say to your husband
hey
this is a this is an issue for me and
this goes just beyond our conversations
we need we need to speak to a
professional what would he say
he would be very open to it he's okay
then let's do it not every hold on not
everything
when it comes to his mom yeah besides
that but but when it comes to his mom
that means food clothing shelter living
in the same state jobs future
besides those few things he makes sure
you're happy
what is what does that mean that he gets
a burger before he comes home like what
does that even mean that he keeps you
happy
here Jade's right Jade's right I I'm
getting frustrated at him and I'm taking
it out on you and that's shame on me so
I'm gonna be quiet now Jade is Right
you've got to sit down with a marriage
counselor one that will do the right
thing and and take sides in the therapy
session and let you you are so convinced
that you're in the wrong and that you're
crazy and you just need to say just the
right thing and then he'll come around
he's not coming around he's picked mom
over you and you are going to have some
hard choices to make moving forward and
you need to get a professional in your
corner
John is telling you the truth I
n z we're not trying to gang up on you
we're simply trying to tell you the
truth and change your situation for the
better this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
all right you're listening to the Ramsay
show my name is Jade warshaw joined to
my right can I say the infamous John
deloney can I say that that's one of the
nicer things I've been called recently
I'll take it we're taking your calls the
numbers triple eight eight two five and
hey if you love this show would you
consider liking it consider sharing it
just tell your folks about it man that's
the best way that things get started is
word of mouth right John that's right
and this is one of those things if it's
helped you which we know it has or if
it's just entertaining to you whatever
that is just tell folks about it we
would appreciate it we want people to
hear this message we know that this
message has the ability to change
people's lives I know it changed in my
life and I heard about it because
somebody told me about it my brother
told me about it heard it on the radio
the rest is history and so you have the
ability uh to be that person in somebody
else's life as well so like subscribe
share definitely leave us some comments
but I don't want to hear any any lick
talk in those comments because I look at
those comments sometimes John and I I
clutch my pearls because I'm like what
you guys can be so mean sometimes so
don't say anything mean dude yeah we get
it enough yeah so if you're not gonna
say something nice say it to James
yes did I say the number wrong you just
said part of it it's cool teamwork man
it makes a Dream Work triple eight eight
two five five two two five thank you
John I have no idea what I said before I
think I was really just thrown off by
this article that Austin uh put in front
of us guys there is an ugly storm
brewing financially there are some
things going on in the world that is
setting us up for some serious
whoo Financial failure here it says as
emergency savings drop and credit card
debt Rises an ugly stew is brewing
Warren's an advocate it says that uh as
high inflation continues and interest
rates go up many people are seeing their
savings dwindle and credit card balances
increase It also says as those debts
become more expensive delinquencies may
be poised to increase not maybe I'm
telling you they are on the rise we can
look and see that people are defaulting
on their credit cards defaulting on
their car loans at higher rates and
really like the Great Recession yeah
2008 2009 that's that's where we're at
right now so let me ask you this um you
look at this data much closer than I do
and it says this survey was
um done in January yep
when I hear household debt is rising to
unprecedented levels and it was the
greatest holiday season ever that tells
me that inflation's uh are hurting
families yes but that these expenses
these extra debt uh the debt
accumulation across the board now
there's going to be individual families
people stuck in in systems I get that
but across the board this tells me that
people are propping up their lifestyle
they're not trying to buy eggs and bacon
and and rice they are trying to keep
their kids in all the travel Sports and
trying to keep their SUVs full right so
they're trying to pop up a lifestyle
with that yeah John in my mind there's
two schools of people here it's like you
said it's the folks who are truly truly
struggling like they're they're they
can't buy groceries right right and then
there's the people who have just decided
that this is a bandwagon thing like oh
helocs are cool I'll get one I need a
new kitchen oh wait we can't like I'm
just gonna get the newest car I need a
Tesla yeah sign me up for for payments
there's the people who are just going
along with whatever culture says like
this is the life you need to live at any
cost basically right and then when
the default starts happening when the
market starts turning when you realize
you're upside down on your car or you
went crazy in 2020 and you're realizing
you're upside down on your house you're
looking around trying to point the
finger but you can't because you chose
to go along with this I wish people
could hear our conversations I've had
conversations with Dave and he said the
words I'm not I'm not spending that on
that yeah it's people of means have
conversations and say less too much I'm
not going to pay that price for this or
I called a con a guy who's going to do
some work on my house yesterday and said
I can't afford this but I can afford
this one yeah so I'm going to do this
work but not this work
but that's not a normal phrase right and
and I I we've got to take into account
things have gotten more expensive they
just have inflation's real we have to
modulate and adjust our lifestyles man
or we're gonna have uh it's gonna be a
mess it it requires a certain level of
self-awareness it requires a certain
level of ownership of your own financial
situation because I mean we know
a lot of people most people aren't
living on a budget right like to know
how you would be surprised when you ask
somebody on the street hey how much
money do you make people can't even
answer that question oh I think it's
like I think like when I get my checks I
think it's like like four thousand like
people don't know the answer 19 bucks an
hour well how much do you make like a
month or a year yeah I don't know yeah
and the more majority of people I read a
set it's over 50 if you ask them hey
what did you spend last month no clue I
can't tell you they can't tell you and
and then we're wondering okay why why is
it that our emergency savings is
dropping why is it that credit card debt
is writing Rising because if you're not
aware if you're not being a good Steward
which is simply being a good manager of
the money that's coming into your hands
yeah you're gonna spend too much of it
and then you're gonna go wait what do I
do oh I know credit card you're gonna
make ends meet with a credit card and
then when that runs out you're gonna go
to the next thing right and how many
people do you know who their car breaks
down yeah they don't have enough cash to
get it fixed so do you know what do you
don't do you know what people do John
they will go finance a new car
because that's it's just money
exchanging I'd Rather Go finance a new
car than shell out 800 to get my car
fixed I don't have any more room on my
credit cards to do that but I can trade
this car up and get a new one and then
you roll that you roll the the negative
equity into your new yeah and then
you're running wondering why you're up a
creek you know yeah and then there's a
note here in this in this I want to make
sure we touch on this younger workers or
more financially fragile
um what does that mean
well my guess is it means two things one
um they don't have the savings built up
and they are they are starting from a
they're starting from scratch if you
will and I think there's some probably
some truth to that okay and
um well it says 45 of Millennials 44 of
gen xers and 38 of ginsiers have more
credit card debt than money in savings
and so I left College my my with my
bachelor's degree this is this is 100
years ago so this sounds like no student
loan debt but at the time it was a
million bucks I left with 17 grand okay
in debt for my bachelor's degree
I finished my first year of working with
a great job 25 or 30 Grand in the hole
on credit card I just because I just
said yes to everything I wanted to do I
feel that YOLO I was gonna and so if you
are a young worker if you're in the
first two or three or four years out of
college in your first job
live a Spartan life and give yourself a
fighting chance to get ahead on the back
end right save and save and save get
roommates live cheap Drive used cars
nobody cares and if he or she does care
you don't want to date him anyway yeah
begin to make that part of your life so
that when these things happen when
you're 35 or 45
it's not so much that you have the
money's fine and the savings account's
fine all that it's you have changed your
character you just handle these problems
in a different way that's true that's a
really good point making that mental
shift early on I it's an identity yeah
I'm not trying to live a life so that
other people can look at what I have and
uh getting my worth and my value from
that you know if you can start that
mindset younger the better and just on a
practical tip if you are young and you
have debt now is the time to get it like
Now's the Time to get after it and pay
it off do it before you get married do
it before you have kids because let me
tell you something the stuff that my
husband and I did to pay off debt it's a
lot easier to do when you don't have
kids oh man everything changes with your
kids man all that side hustling all
those those meal you know all that stuff
it's it's easier when you're on your own
and then it's easier when you don't have
kids don't get me wrong when you have
kids and all this you can still do it
but if you're one of these Jen's ears
one of these gen xers and you're you're
struggling now is the time to get after
it do not wait do not put it off please
now is the time to get after that
because this is this is a this is a
problem like they said it's an ugly stew
Brewing I think that's funny that they
wrote it like that but I mean we get to
choose that's the best part about this
John is we get to choose what we're
going to participate in and um you don't
have to participate in debt that's
optional right you know if you are one
of those folks who have found yourselves
out in the margins and you are really
struggling reach out for help let
somebody know I'm not all right I need
some support I got to figure something
else out I need uh call one of our
Ramsay coaches and get some get some
some direct support but if you're just
propping up a lifestyle man you gotta
choose reality you've got to choose
reality because reality is going to
choose you if you're not here yeah and
you can stop today
it'll time to make a difference get on a
budget that's thing one if you're
listening to this show keep listening to
this show we'll talk we will talk to you
about budgets uh until your ears fall
off we will make sure you understand
what it takes for you to get hold of
your financial situations this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show I'm Jade warshaw
your host and we're talking about your
life and your money give us a call the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five we got Brian in
Nashville what's going on Brian how can
we help
hey I need your advice I have a house
that I just completed a Cash out
refinance on in order to pay for repairs
it would have depleted my on hand
emergency Reserve to basically nothing
okay so I owe 149 000 and it is
refinanced on a 15-year fixed okay on
Dave's advice
um now this is where the interesting
part comes in over the past 10 plus
years I've been spending stupid amounts
of money North to my parents Dave said I
was enabling them and I needed to cut
them off so I did okay now they're
finally selling property and I'm going
to be receiving a hundred thousand
dollars as repayment for all the money I
have sent them through the years okay my
question is this
given the current economic climate do I
pay or take that hundred thousand
dollars and pay down the house and then
try to pay the house off and pull up we
can probably do it in a year and a half
to two years if I try really hard or do
I split it between half on the house
half investing or do I move it all into
investing my initial reaction is to pay
down the house it's always nice to have
a safe base of operations
um I have no other debt other than the
house right um that's a good question
Brian and you also said that you
depleted your emergency fund to zero
right
no no no I would have if I had paid for
the house repairs that's why I did the
cash out refund I see okay so how much
do you how much cash do you have on hand
uh probably
23 no 25 000 okay and that's the
emergency fund okay yeah so if you are
in baby step six I would and you're
already putting 15 to retirement all
that deal
yes
then I would put this money towards the
house that's what I'd do okay how old
are you man yeah
I'm sorry how old are you
oh uh I'll be 52 in April
yeah I would I it feels good I it's just
me I'm just telling you I I'm your
neighbor here so I'm just telling you
what I would do
um I I you said it it's a home base of
operations there's something about
having no liabilities hanging out there
when the weather gets tough if I think
about it on furniture on my front porch
right when he's these wild wind storms
keep coming through town I don't want
any furniture on the front porch and so
I'm gonna go through and knock out any
existing liabilities I have and you got
a big one a house and then you just
leveraged your house you put it on the
Block right so I'm gonna get that sucker
off the block and make it mine and then
I'll start thinking about
um putting some stuff in the in the barn
right which is which is your retirement
but I want to get rid of those I want to
get rid of that stuff man
yeah I'm giving the legal maximum to the
401K matching that the state of
Tennessee provides since I worked for
the state but until I pay off the last
of the debt I just it just doesn't feel
right to put more into that pay off the
house Own It Free and Clear then I can
go nuts dumping everything into
retirement uh yeah that's right Brian
and basically all we're telling Brian to
do is work the baby steps the baby steps
work like that for a reason baby step
six you're paying off the house you've
got this big windfall of cash that's
exactly what you would do and like you
said in in a year or so you're going to
be done with the house and then you can
put whatever extra money you want into
your investments from there well beyond
15 you know and you've got lots and lots
of options there very good thanks for
the call Brian let's check out what's
going on in Toronto we've got Elias what
can we do for you uh Elias
uh hi I'm glad to uh be here
um just have a question maybe get some
advice from you about my situation which
is I am a 38 year old man uh with a
seven month old baby and uh I am I'm
married and uh right now the housing
market is very expensive in Toronto and
the interest rates are very high I do
have a hundred I do have a hundred and
eighty thousand dollar down payment
ready to go for a home
um it's just that right now it seems
that if we were to jump into the market
we would be house poor yeah so I was
wondering if um it'd be okay to rent for
a few years until I would be able to
save enough money where
the expenses the uh the mortgage and
everything else would be 25 or less of
my monthly income Bingo yeah what you're
saying is exactly right and um yeah I I
know for whatever reason people get
really hung up on on renting but it's
only for a season right it's just for a
season so that you can buy this house
the proper way in a way that it can
actually be a blessing for you and so
that you're not house poor
um Elias I think that you're thinking
exactly on the right track because I I'm
not an expert at the real estate market
in Toronto but I know that you ain't
getting out of there for less than a
million probably in some areas
um 180k what what percentage of a down
payment is that
um I guess it would be close to 20 20
maybe uh for an 800 now maybe more than
20 for an 800 000 home yeah yeah so yeah
if I'm you I mean how how much longer
would you need to rent to get enough of
a down payment to purchase a house where
you know it is a 15-year fix where the
payment isn't more than 25 of your
take-home pay all included how much
longer would that take
uh right actually in Canada it's uh I
don't think it's the same as the United
States where they have a 15-year fix
okay what's the equivalent okay
it's probably like six would probably be
like uh a five year or three year
and then there's also variable rate
mortgage which is considerably higher uh
interest rate don't do that yeah don't
do anything that's variable there's no
fixed rate mortgage in Canada
there's fixed rate mortgage uh for three
to four or five years and then and then
it variates
and then and then there's the variable
rates which are a little bit higher
everybody that I'm talking to especially
um orange Brokers are saying I should go
with variable because the Elias Elias
listen to me listen to me I don't get
anybody any mortgage broker is trying to
do one thing get paid make money and
they're making on your back do not do
not do not get a an adjustable rate
mortgage
don't do it here's why you have
absolutely zero control over what your
payment is two years five years ten
years down the road yeah so it doesn't
matter the how your house appreciates
doesn't matter because some government
official is going to tell you what your
house payment is down the street don't
do it I mean down the road don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it lock it in or don't buy a
house yeah I'm I'm with I'm with John on
this do what you do keep renting save up
a nice little a stack of money and then
when the time comes you're gonna be able
to get the house that is right for you
the house that you can actually
um afford really really great call you
know these are the types of things that
we're talking about
um on the show just situations with
money everyday money and we've got
actually a set of live events coming up
John yeah to the people with these very
things how how to buy homes how to build
wealth how to to resist the
Ridiculousness of the world John tell
them about it real quick before I tell
them about this like I I want to point
out to Elias that's devastating
uh young married family young kid we
gotta get a house we have almost 200
Grand and you're telling me we can't yes
that's what we're telling you yeah and
it's not because we
AK rain on people's parade because I
love you yeah it's because thank you
it's because we love you we do not want
you to feel the feeling of not being can
because look at the adverse being in a
house with a 10 month old with your wife
and you can't make the payments and and
I have it it's stamped on my soul in
2008 2009 people were living in a
million dollar house that overnight was
worth 600 Grand and their rates their
mortgage rates went up right so they're
paying more for that yeah don't do it
man don't do it don't do it don't I just
I just remember those faces of people
who felt like they had lost everything
yeah well they did and you know what I
mean don't do it don't I know it's
heartbreaking man don't do it
um just rent a little bit longer yes
both you and I have rented and it's life
I've rented for 10 years yeah can't
nobody tell me nothing exactly hey we're
less than one month away from Building
Wealth live in Salt Lake City we've been
having a blast at these events the
venues have been packed it's super fun
to be with everybody in person tickets
are going super fast it's going to be
Dave Rachel George words Jade's going to
be there April 24th and they're about to
speed up because right now through April
3rd you can get buy one get one free
tickets that's two golly dudes give them
away two tickets for 49 bucks or a four
pack of tickets for 75 bucks just use
the code night out
n-i-g-h-t-o-u-t if you're in Salt Lake
City
um you're gonna get financial wisdom
advice you trust like on topics like
inflation massive layoffs investment
make it a date night take your friends
go buy yourself whatever you got to do
Salt Lake City April 21st and 24th go to
ramseysolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com events we'll see you
there this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
next to me and hey if you're new
listener and you want to dive deeper
into the Ramsay baby steps go over to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and we're going to help
you figure out the best next step for
your financial Journey based on exactly
where you're at today that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started and it's really just good to get
over there anyway on this show we use a
lot of lingo we're talking about baby
steps we're talking about a lot of
different things and if you're kind of
like what the heck are you talking about
this is a great uh place to get started
so go over there click the get started
button and uh we'll get you right all
right let's take another call John we
got Tyler from Columbus Ohio what's
going on in your world Tyler
how are you guys doing doing good man
how are you
oh not too bad uh I'll keep it simple I
guess the reason for my call is so we
have our baby step two we've got about
uh 90 000 and that give or take a couple
hundred okay we make about 90 000 a year
most of it is my wife's student loans uh
we had some credit card trouble we were
in our early 20s okay we were doing
really well we knocked out about six
thousand dollars in debt and about six
thousand or about six months I'm sorry
and then we had our second child uh I
was injured at work for about three and
a half months so I wasn't able to do any
overtime wasn't able to do really
anything
uh so we're just kind of getting back
into it but we depleted our emergency
fund we're just trying to figure out how
to get back into the
swing of things is now balancing
obviously and two children a
five-year-old and a six month old now
that that injury that we're kind of
nursing yeah Tyler how are you doing
with that injury
that's good I finally got to go back to
work but you know still nervous to pick
back up uh 80 hours a week given the
small enforcement so it's kind of a give
it a take yeah well you know the the
tough news is you're starting over again
but the good news is you know how to do
it because you did it one time before
and so the technique doesn't change much
you know you're trying to you're
scratching to get that thousand dollars
saved right when you said your emergency
fund you were talking about the starter
emergency fund right
correct yeah thousand dollars thanks to
you guys we actually had a thousand
dollar save for the first time in our
entire life that's amazing does your
wife work man
uh she does so we've combined and make
about 90 90 to 95 a year okay
that's good so what's keeping you from
getting
I mean I know you've got 90k mostly
student loans you said credit cards is
it just the budget is super tight you've
got no margin at this point
uh yeah it was really tight and then I
was working literally 80 hours a week uh
and that was how we were paying
everything down we were making
incredible progress like I said really I
guess it was three months because yeah
three months I was injured you know but
then I got hurt and then it was like
well if I pick back up all those hours
again I run that same risk of getting
hurt and now maybe something else
happens you know so she's kind of like a
do you have a chance to do you have a
chance to to could you sit in and do
dispatch or could you sit in and do
um IA or could you do some other desk
job for those for those overtime hours
so
uh part of it yeah it's like uh we so I
can do that I guess I didn't consider
that stuff it's not it's not sexy and
it's not cool and it's it's I mean it
can be lame just downright Lane but
um we're thinking of what's some
short-term pain we can go through for
some long term gain um can I ask you one
more uh hard question that it pains me
to ask but it's just the reality
um
is this your Forever calling or is there
another job you could go take out in the
community that would be 50 or 60 hours
40 50 hours a week that you could double
your income
uh yeah and this is what I want to do
since I was a kid you know my grand
great grandfather was the deputy sheriff
this is what my my dad was a prosecutor
you know this is what my
whole family has done is you know I got
into it to help people and I got I got
you man that's my old man I've I've
worked alongside officers my whole
career too I get it and there's also an
unfortunate reality that our communities
don't pay our policemen enough
yeah and so there's just a truth to that
too right so
um what about
um what's your wife do
so she's a administrator for uh one of
the local counties around us okay does
she have an opportunity from for a
different job yeah I was gonna say what
portion of this 90k is her salary
uh
uh I would what do you mean by like what
portion is her salary like so the 90k is
that YouTube combined
yes yes so I make about
63 she makes about 30 she's got a race I
think it's because it's like 39 here
next month okay she got a 3 000 raise I
would love to see I would love to see a
track for you guys to get your income up
I think long term
it's gonna behoove you especially if you
want to get this debt paid off right now
more practically I want to know with
your but you guys are budgeting right
I'm assuming yes
yes we've been doing a written budget
okay for the past six months just so I
kind of notepads and stuff okay after
you've paid before we get off the line
today I'm going to have Austin gift you
with every dollar because I think that
there's going to be a a better way for
you to budget and I think that you may
end up finding more margin in your
budget to get this uh thousand dollars
paid off because right now what is the
percentage I mean how much money do you
have once you've paid all your bills
everything what do you have left
uh typically speaking so we get paid
bi-weekly like one uh check we'll get
about like 700 maybe left evidence for
groceries and gas and stuff and then the
next check it can vary you know maybe
it's 300 or 400 you know yeah so that's
not leftovers if it's earmarked for
something then it's not left over what
I'm trying to get at is if you know your
number is enough to know hey after
everything is said and done I got 500
and and I get to decide what I'm gonna
do with that 500 that's what I'm trying
to get you to to the point that you know
your month and you know your expenses
and you're so chopped down that you know
hey out of out of the 5 000 bucks we
have a month we spend you know four
thousand and seventy five dollars of it
and we've got this much left over that's
where I want you to be because that when
you know your numbers like that that
means that you're you are intent on
making progress because you know that
you know every two weeks I've got 173
dollars left and I that's where I want
you to be with this Tyler so I feel like
right now your numbers are a little
wacky wavy and it's probably because
you're sending here doing your budget on
a yellow pad I've been there but we're
going to give you every dollar and we're
going to make it a lot easier for you to
see your numbers to see it in real time
for you to work together with your wife
on this because with your income I think
that you should have some margin at the
end of the month I think you should be
able to knock out getting this thousand
dollars saved whether that means selling
something whether that means your wife
picking up some income we got to get
this thousand dollars saved fast because
as you know that's your barrier uh
between you and Calamity you know what
I'm saying John and you know this Tyler
but I'm going to say this for the
audience
you're uh six month old and that
five-year-old they don't need brand new
clothes no they don't need the best of
everything and the perfect of everything
and especially that little six month old
that weighs 16 pounds doesn't need a
fully furnished pinster pin Pinterest I
don't even know Instagram Instagrams not
even a thing that's satanic uh they
don't need a uh pentagram room all
dolled up that's gonna cost a million
yeah right not pentagrams it kind of
worked out that way it's kind of
fantastic they need
um they need their mom and dad to
um get their lives back yeah right way
more than they need a bunch of junk and
a bunch of garbage and a bunch of
plastic toys they're gonna forget about
it they need Mom and Dad to be whole and
to be whole you gotta you gotta pay this
crap off yeah that's true it's tough
there there is something that happens
I'm not gonna lie John when we when we
had our first kid I I went off I I I I I
I bought all the things that the
Instagrams tells you that you need to
buy I bought y'all there's this sock
it's not even a sock it's a little thing
that you put on their foot when they're
infants and it tells you their heartbeat
oh Lord it tells you now I'm not gonna
lie it was It was kind of dope though I
got I got some sleep knowing it because
it'll go off it'll go off of something
do you know what that thing costs you
don't want to know you know what I did
this I slept fine I slept great did you
I did not know my any of Yes man I
bought the cameras I bought I bought all
different things yeah man I saw Blair
Witch Project I Don't Need No cameras in
my house we were newly out of debt we
were we were just past baby step two
start on baby step three and I felt like
ready to go man I felt like I won the
lottery I was I spent 500 on that no no
I did I got some yeah I don't even tell
you what I spent on my socks I think
five dollars yeah no this was the baby
socket for the package of 30. that's
what I'm saying for the little kid socks
but hey uh but when you don't owe
anybody any money you can do that right
you can do that I bought the organic
diapers and you know what happens to
those you don't even know what an
organic diaper I did I did you can do
organic in a diaper but I didn't know
they were oh man well guys that does it
for this hour be sure to join us next
time and remember this when it comes to
changing your life and your money you
can tell me that you won't do it but
please don't tell me that you can't with
Christ all things are possible
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help you build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships that's what
we're helping you do today give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're here
hanging out we're talking about whatever
it is that you want to talk about as
long as it has something to do with
money relationships careers give us a
call and uh we'll chop it up with you
let's take a call we got Elizabeth from
Nashville what's going on Elizabeth how
can we help today
hey guys how are you doing good how are
you
good okay I hopefully have a simple
question
um okay so me and my husband were
talking uh last night about the budget
and we were just we were a little
stumped on on something should we be
saving any of our money just to save
money like we do have some things we'd
like to save for and we're putting money
aside for that but should we be saving
money just to save money are you on baby
step three or baby step one
so we have the emergency fund fifteen
thousand dollars our monthly expenses
are about three we have a thousand
dollars in a separate of fun separate
funds that like all the bills come out
and we that that thousand is basically
like Euro
um we're investing six percent
um and we're only doing that because we
are technically at baby step three d's
and we're trying to save somewhere
between 1500 to 2 2500 a month
um for for a down payment cool cool cool
cool cool cool very cool outside of the
emergency fund outside of like thinking
funds should we just should we be saving
some money just to save money well
also would it be wrong like if we had
money saved up would it be wrong to use
that money if something came up and we
were like oh I'd like new kayaks or
shoes or something okay yeah I hear what
you're saying um
so I do want to call out the fact that
you're you guys have got your own system
that you're working
um it's not the baby steps and that's
fine if you want to work whatever system
that you Elizabeth and your husband want
to work but mostly what are we doing
wrong okay I'm glad you asked thank you
for asking Elizabeth you shouldn't have
done that no that was good because if if
she had it was choose her own adventure
there for a minute John if she had
chosen to be like what no what do you
mean then we would have been we would
have gotten gotten into it but Elizabeth
is like I want to learn help me I love
it Elizabeth okay so here's what I'll
call out
um you really only need that thousand
dollar saved starting out that's baby
step one your starter emergency fund
that's a barrier between you and life 56
of Americans don't have anything they
can't cover a thousand dollar emergency
so by you just having that thousand
dollars you have set yourself up uh so
far ahead of society so that's thing one
thing two do you guys have debt
no okay baby step two is done number
that's wonderful baby step three it said
that you you said you had 1500 set aside
somewhere oh fifteen thousand
fifteen thousand oh sweet and then you
said you had another fund of a thousand
dollars okay so we're getting there okay
and then three B just like if we have
the thousand in there it's just like a
buffer between like if something happens
and uh we don't want to touch the
emergency fund uh it's an emergency fund
for your emergency fund
yeah it's that's where all the bills
come out and so like if something
happens I see yeah it's just it's like a
little cushion yeah
I'm not gonna yell at you for that I'm
not I I get it some people do it I
probably wouldn't do it you got fifteen
thousand dollars but I get it I'm not
gonna yell at you about that
um are you guys saving up for a house is
that again I got you yeah that's where
we're at we're at baby step 3B okay so
technically you're not at baby step four
yet so I don't know that I would be
contributing to
you know investing just yet if you're in
3B and you're trying to like
kick this thing out
um I thought Dave said you could do like
a little mix of both you could it just
depends on what what your goals are if
you're trying to hurry up and do this or
not
because I mean technically the baby
steps work in order
um but like if you were a person and you
were already in the house and you're
saving for another house I wouldn't tell
you to stop investing to save for
another house do you see what I'm saying
like I wouldn't have you go backwards in
that way so if you want to do a little
mix of it I'm not mad at that but if
you're trying to move quickly I'd
probably hold up for a minute and walk
the baby steps exactly in order
I hear you you know what I'm saying so
yeah
um can I can I ask you this Elizabeth
what what are you scared it's gonna
happen
what do you mean John you've got you've
got layer on top of layer on top you are
trying to insulate yourself from the
world fortification Maybe
um what are you what are you scared is
gonna happen
John I went in debt and I never want to
do it again
okay
having a little cushion let me just say
this in the account that you're paying
your bills from having a line item in
your budget that's like hey no matter
what there's always five hundred dollars
here and no matter what there's always
200 here I'm not mad at that I think if
it gets excessive it could be an
indicator of possibly something else so
Elizabeth yesterday I was talking to
um his name is Sal de Stefano he's a
good buddy of mine and he is with the
Mind pump guys in San Jose they are they
basically are doing for the Fitness and
Nutrition industry what Dave is doing
has done for 30 years for the finance
industry I trust the guy and he's
brilliant here's what he told me he said
most
um people fail I think it's up to 90
percent of workouts and diets fail
because people are they don't like what
they see in the mirror so much they are
exercising because they hate themselves
and so exercise becomes a form of
punishment for how I look for how I've
eaten and what he said is with you you
go into the gym to exercise as a form of
punishment you you deserve a hard
workout today because of how you look
and how you eat and how lazy you are and
these are these are all things we're
saying to ourselves that that is going
to fail it's gonna fail and so what I
want to tell you is
you went into debt you did
and you owned reality and you and your
husband have worked your butts off
I want you at some point to stop
punishing yourself and stop setting up
all these curbs for what if I do it
again because that's not you anymore
and I want you to start going to
something not dragging around this past
and trying to create all these imaginary
buffers for things that for ways you
might do something stupid again that's
not who you are anymore
and go towards something right so when
people go to the gym because they know
they're worth that hour
when they eat right because I know how
good I'm gonna feel tomorrow when I wake
up those people stick to those diets
that's you're talking about identity
change and that's what we're that's
that's that's what I'm talking about
here I want you to give some credit to
my new friend Elizabeth that that
um that that that's your past you've
been there and we're gonna we're gonna
follow these baby steps all the way to
the end and we're gonna wake up
millionaires in a few years
um because we we started going towards
something not we didn't continue to run
from things does that make sense
it makes I hear you doing yep that's so
good Elizabeth you're doing everything
right John I love what you just said
you're talking to me on that Elizabeth
he was talking to both of us on that one
no I appreciate the call hey if you want
to buy Elizabeth if you want to buy
kayaks save up some money and buy some
kayaks okay you're out of baby step two
do it do a little something something
you got your baby step three done yeah
you can buy organic diapers you can buy
kayaks still don't even know what that
means but get them anyway get them
anyway you can spend a little bit of
your money remember you can give your
money you can save your money uh you can
spend your money and don't forget to
have a little bit of fun with this you
know what I'm saying guys this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw your host joined by Dr John
deloney and we're taking calls about
your life and your money give us a call
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five and uh you know
we'll talk it up with you we'll chop it
up with you we'll give you advice we'll
help you out with whatever it is that
you feel like you need help with let's
take a quick call from Brady in Orlando
Florida what's going on Bradley
hey guys uh it's good to hear from you
you too how can we help today
um so my wife and I are expecting our
first child uh in October hey congrats
that's exciting thank you thank you and
so we have enough cash to pay off our
car loan
but I've heard you guys you know say
you know save up
just for anything like expectant
anything that can happen between now and
then
um I was just kind of curious of like my
situation
uh we owe like 9 700 and we have about
000 total in savings
but I know within those six months we
could you know grind and get back up to
where we are
Jay tell me I'm wrong I would do both uh
I would keep that we we call it stork
mode around here but I would I don't see
a problem with keeping that money in
your account and working like crazy
until that baby comes and then being
able to write that check for the car
when you find when the when the
everything goes smooth with the birth
everything's nice and good you got that
kid sitting at home everybody smiling
and um then you can just write to get
online write that check and be done with
it and and also you've already it's it's
already been replaced in your emergency
fund right it's it's two birds one stone
yeah it's kind of a wash yeah yeah
that's exactly what I would do nothing
stopping you from putting that money on
the car once everything goes smooth and
everything goes well and you've got it
stockpiled there
um is there any other debt to speak of
or it's just the 9700
uh just a house but that's different
okay yeah I'm sitting here thinking Jada
and Bradley I I wouldn't
I don't know if I'd be able to breathe
if I had a baby on the way and had five
thousand bucks no I I would not
liquidate I would not liquidate the
savings to do that I would keep that
there I do what John said I continue to
work hard continue to stack up as much
money as I can and then when baby comes
pay off the car and you'll have some
extra money in savings as well yeah that
feels right yeah because I know well I
know we'll have the car paid off
probably within the next five six months
anyways because we put down you know
almost triple quadruple sometimes yeah I
mean so yeah baby step baby steps
speaking let's say there was no baby on
the way of course you would liquidate
this 14k and take the 9700 and pay it in
this case we don't want to do that for
the reasons that John said it's it's
actually the opposite you want to stop
going crazy and pile up cash
um so in that case yeah something tells
me that in the next six months you're
probably gonna make enough an extra
money that you could pay off this car
and keep the 14k there something tells
me you're going to be able to make that
happen am I am I close
yeah and the other thing holding me back
was just because my wife's planning on
taking off a year so oh so you need to
stack up even more get back our salary
which will cut back our salary you know
total by how much
uh he's a teacher so it's a little over
40 so
what's that what's that car note
per month yeah
uh 500. okay so that's that's not not
the entirety of her paycheck
before she yeah takes off right so when
she stops working and that 40 000 is out
of your equation how much are you
bringing in
oh about 70. okay so you guys can live
off of that
yeah all right cool especially
especially with no payments right yeah I
like that plan I think that's great
again you know a lot of what we teach
here is so that you can have options to
do that kind of stuff it's Freedom it's
just yeah you can choose freedom to be
able to say hey we can forego your 40
000 income and we can just skate on 70.
that's what I'm talking about and let's
let's be super honest you may not get
super you might you may take a year off
of getting really really far ahead right
yes and that's okay you gotta you got a
brand new baby enjoy enjoy that baby
yeah yeah help your help out around the
house look let me tell you I would
rather be free and and be on that
Corolla life than all day man then be
working and need all the paychecks and
all the money and to support all the
debt so I can drive I don't know the the
BMW or drive that Mercedes man I would
rather just be free I don't know about
you I will drive some used vehicles with
a hundred thousand miles on it in a
second John for some Freedom out here
all right our question of the day is
brought to you by name your hub for Home
Services when you need to make repairs
when you need to schedule routine
maintenance or find local help Home
Improvement projects neighborly is your
source for Reliable home service
providers in your area so go to
neighborly.com to start your search all
right today's question comes from Sal in
Virginia sell writes I've pretty much
dug a hole for myself with so much debt
which I barely which I'm barely able to
keep up on the payments I went over my
limits on several credit cards and have
a few loans and I'm very close to
hitting ninety thousand dollars in debts
I want to know if it's okay to
temporarily stop paying for some of the
big payments and focus on the smaller
payments first and then focus on the
bigger payments I'm just unable to make
all the payments and be able to pay for
other necessary things like rent utility
and transportation
for the past few months the past couple
of months I've actively tried to sell
more of my belongings which I really
don't need I've also taken on a couple
of weekend jobs but I'm still struggling
to keep up please advise on my best
option to getting back on track before I
try the baby steps man this is it's a
mess I'm so grateful for this question
um Sal because you know on this show
John we yell out folks all the time look
at how you're spending your money you're
not doing it right all this stuff but
this is this is real deal right here
because this is somebody who they're
doing the best they can they made some
mistakes and you know they're just
trying to make ends meet so and let's
let's be real honest there does come a
moment when you've dug yourselves quite
a hole and you can work two or three
jobs and any it ain't you're making a
dent in that hole man you're preaching
to the choir it just is right and so
it's easy for us to be like you just
need to get out there and get another
job and a third job sometimes you dug
yourself a hole and it's a mess look I
re when I when you read Sal's question I
relate directly to that and I hope that
Sal and anybody else listening knows man
back in gosh Sam what was it back in
2012 2011.
um we were in exactly cell situation so
much debt so many payments we literally
couldn't pay them all we had to stop
with some of them and just
tell the others to take a hike be like
hey you're just gonna have to call my
phone and that's what I you know I refer
to that I know people call Baby Step
Zero different things for us baby Step
Zero was simply quit creating more debt
like if you can just stop stop like not
drown and not make the water any deeper
that is successful and that was uh gosh
almost two years of the first part of
our journey was just trying to get
enough footing to where we could just
pay all of our bills
um so I understand what that means and
when you're in that situation you've got
to focus on that four walls you've got
to focus on hey I gotta keep the rent
going like I can't default on my rent I
can't get evicted that's number one You
Gotta Eat You Gotta make sure that
there's food coming in you're eating you
got to keep the lights on utilities
that's next and you got to get
Transportation it doesn't have to be
expensive Transportation I don't care
for taking the bus you got to make sure
there's money for gas bus ticket Uber
ride whatever it is that you need to do
to get by and if you're able to do that
you can read it night and can we just
this isn't to celebrate us this is just
to to just provide a picture of what
this looks like I have rented an
upstairs bedroom in my friend's mom's
house before I have driven a 3500 truck
to my Dina students job come on I have
you know I'm saying like I've given my
wife's old used Corolla that she sold
and I bought back at a lesser you know
what I mean yeah like you just I know
you guys I mean you and Sam jeez man
y'all went through it right look I
remember on a Friday having no money in
the account I would I would go to the
grocery store because we needed food I'd
write a bad check on a Friday knowing
that check can't clear on Saturday
Sunday that gave me two days it gave Sam
and I two days I'd teach lessons I'd do
anything I could to get money in the
account before Monday so it wouldn't
overdraw right sometimes we did it
sometimes we decided to eat today right
Gotta Eat You Gotta Eat and it that was
it was like I knew to do that because
I'm like okay they can't they can't
charge this check over the weekend this
is my chance so I get it if you're out
there and you're struggling I see that
when I'm out here you're going on a rail
and yelling at folks I'm not talking to
you I know that you're scratching your
claw and you're doing whatever you need
to do to get by the folks I'm yelling at
is the people who can pay their bills
who are sitting on their hands while the
government is holding your student loans
off and you're waiting for that single
person to pay that bill for you you're
the one that needs to get off your butt
and do some work this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
what's up guys you're listening to the
Ramsey show my name is Jade warshaw I am
joined by Dr John deloney and we are
taking calls this hour about your life
your money your relationships what's
going on with the government what's
going on with taxes what's going on with
my job what's going on with my family
whatever it is give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we are here for you we're ready to talk
about it we got Carolyn we got Carol and
Edmond okay I got to put my glasses on
so I can read a little bit better what's
going on Carol hi can you hear me okay I
definitely can what's up okay
um I am 67 my husband is 66. I have
cancer my husband has enough he is 100
percent of disability retired from VA
with the VA hold on a second Cara hold
on a second Carol tell me tell me about
your cancer I'm so sorry me too oh um
well I had into mutual cancer in 2015.
um I still am stable but I had to get
off all of my
um
treatment because it was causing too
many complications hypertensive crisis
but I'm stable I just I know you're
stable but that's a brutally painful
cancer right
um I'm doing okay I know but don't just
wipe you you have a right to your pain
too okay
and this is coming from your friend I'm
doing pretty good right now I have uh go
every three months for screening so
um my husband bad enough he was the
Coronet soloist the United States Marine
band and developed multiple sclerosis oh
man and two in 1989 and retired in 1990
okay he is basically in a wheelchair now
so his disposal went up to 100 okay
um he retired he was a college professor
for 25 years and it's longer than that
really and he retired in 2020. we
refinanced our house to 2.65 okay
um and we do not have to pay property
tax because he is 100 disabled okay so
our monthly income is approximately
92 100 a month with Social Security
which we took early because of our
health
um his VA disability and his pension
which I am entitled to when he passes
that's the way the Oklahoma teacher's
retirement works here okay so the
pension is good for you wonderful yeah
okay so we are completely out of debt
except for our house because we got a
PhD in the UMD and went on to do
postgraduate work we are behind in our
retirement we have approximately three
hundred thousand dollars in retirement
we do not have to touch that right now
we our expenses are about 4 500 a month
I just did our budget and it's 4
000 something without
um you know fluctuating on our um
electric and we ask sure so at any rate
um our question is okay we we don't know
our financial advisors said throw
everything at the house get it paid off
if you really want to get it paid off
get it paid off yeah but I'm concerned
because if I pass first he's fine he
doesn't lose anything if he passes first
they slash his VA disability
um and how much of the 9200 is that
oh let's see he gets about 3 900 and it
would go down to about 14.51 because
he's only been 100 for three years now
to be at least 10 years to get so you go
down to a little under 8 000 a month
probably yeah hey Carol when that hold
on Carol when that happens
you want zero liabilities
right and but the thing is I want to
know if we should
follow exactly the baby steps and put
15 keep putting 15 percent into retire
Investments to catch up
and then still pay the house off because
we've been putting about 2 000 a month
towards the principles how much left how
much left do you have on that house uh
the house is worth 365 and we have 151
left as of now when I make another
payment
um when the new month comes it'll be a
little lower plus the what we throw at
the mortgage I could sell it and still
get a good profit but I'd really rather
have
it paid off in case I don't want to move
can I ask you a hard question Carol yeah
what's PR what's what's precipitating
this call is is somebody get get a bad
diagnosis
no we've just been thinking about this
um when we he retired and we
um realized we needed to get our Affairs
in order because of my cancer and his Ms
we all went to our attorney and our
financial planner we got our estate in
order we got everything DNR and all that
but you you you could be each one of you
could be 5 10 15 more years 20 more
years
okay well here's here's the thing you're
you're in a good position because you've
got the 300 000 Nest Egg but you're not
touching it all the money all this 9200
is from Social Security uh VA and
pension aside from that 300K right
but we don't and we only spend about
with our bills right you're only
spending 4 500.
approximately so it depends on what our
electrical gas is if something if it
were different if you were like the 300K
is all we have and our social security
is only 1800 then I'd be like you can't
keep this house but because you're not
touching this Nest Egg it does have the
ability to grow I I'm with your
financial advisor I'd work to get this
house paid down
Carol if you were my mom and she's just
south of you uh and across the border in
Texas if we were sitting down having
this conversation I would tell my mom
I want no matter what happens to Dad I
want to make sure you've got a house
that nobody can come take that from you
and so I would do everything I could
because what you're exchanging is this
illusion that I'm going to put this
money in the market and it's going to
replace that
that amount of money
I would technically lose in the VA
payments and why don't you just wipe out
your your house payment and you get to
the same place if but you're more secure
and even if even if the worst were
happening and you did lose that VA
payment you're still making eight
thousand dollars a month it's not like
it's taking you down at two thousand or
something like that you still have a
nice amount of money to live off of and
it's still far more than what you need
so we're not extraving people we don't I
mean sure you know we are going to have
to get another person we have uh what
2009 Subaru which I love and I'll keep
till I die if I could
those things will run for a long time we
kept our other one for 17 years until my
husband had an accident and that's when
he found out he couldn't drive anymore
because he had optic neuritis and didn't
know it and he could have been bad
here's a here's a common thing
and I'm speaking about something I've
only had conversations about I've never
personally experienced okay
you have had to stare down
cancer
you have had to watch someone you love
who was the picture of strength and the
and who led
entire
um
groups of of men and women as the
strongest you've watched his body revolt
against him and take him and fold him up
and so you have seen what some of what
most of us only like think could
possibly happen someday you've
experienced it and so often when that
happens we try to to mitigate every
single variable in our life and we do
that by holding everything really really
really tight
and what we do is we suffocate the joy
and the breath and the laughter out of
the last few precious moments we have
and so I want to tell you
um jade and I take calls with people who
call in in a similar situation and they
have zero
right and so I want you to see the
you've got nine thousand dollars coming
in
and you've got a nest egg is it a
million dollars is it Dave Ramsey's
house no it's 300 000 bucks you can get
through the end of your life and never
ever touch that thing yep because you
got money coming in
I want you to open your hands open your
hands open your hands
y'all done so good so good you're doing
better than you think you are pay your
house off yeah take out the liabilities
take out the risk and then look at that
precious husband of yours and say let's
just have fun until the wheels fall off
here yep y'all are doing so good guys
this is why we say this is why we say
get your money in order get your life in
order it may not be raining yet but at
some point it's going to rain and you're
gonna wish that you had your money set
up uh Carol's situation it's stressful
and it there's some sad things going on
but her money is not the problem this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
to the Ramsay show I'm Jade warshaw your
host joined by my co-host today Dr John
deloney what's going on with you John
doing all you know it's a heavy it's a
heavy heavy time here in Nashville it's
almost gonna say it's all right but it's
not it's a it's a tough tough tough day
here in Nashville yeah we got a lot of
things going on we got some things going
on but um we're here to take your calls
we'll talk about your life we'll talk
about your money give us a call the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five in the meantime John
we need a little we need a little hope
in the world right now
so let's talk about Financial Peace
University I love this topic because
it's all about the hope so with that
payments and now inflation uh stealing
more and more of your paycheck we know a
lot of you feel like you're drowning
I've been there done that got the
T-shirt Shrunk the t-shirt and now
you're scared to death that you won't
have enough money to take care of your
family man you shouldn't have to live
like that with that kind of stress but
if you want these things to change
you've got to say that I've had it I've
decided to try new things I'm doing
something different with my money I'm
not repeating the same old cycle and
that means it's time to try Financial
Peace University this is our nine lesson
course that'll teach you how to beat
debt and build wealth it's everything
that you wish you'd learned in in school
really about how to handle money I'm
actually teaching a FPU class uh group
of it started with a thousand folks John
we got one class left tomorrow and when
I tell you these people are in here
changing their lives so when you hear me
say stats like nearly 10 million people
have taken FPU and they don't you know
they don't worry about money like they
used to they're in control and you can
be too these are real people sitting in
real seats making real decisions it's
not just like oh 10 million people no
these are real people in daily life I'm
one of them they're really changing
their lives you've got to decide that
you're done stressing out about money
you've got to take control start
Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com
FPU hey let me tell you this
um we talk about uh
they don't worry about money like they
used to yeah I've got buddies who don't
owe anybody any money at all none yeah
did you know the last six months all the
conversations are about all the
opportunity out there now man yes all
the it's it's like you watch the news
and it's the end of time and I walk we
have these big TVs back in the meet in
the pr area where the media is and it's
all these red arrows pointing down and
all these pundits talking about the End
of Time yeah
all the folks I'm talking to have Smiles
on the face because it's opportunity
time it's buying season it's it's hey we
could possibly do this and I could
possibly get this it's probably the
right time to buy this it's a totally
different this everything is different
because they don't owe anybody any money
they're taking control of their life can
I tell you that back in 2008 2009 when
the world was just crashing down on us
that was when Sam and I were just in the
thick we had just gotten married student
loans coming due everything is just I
mean
I can't say the words that I want to say
on the radio it was terrible and I
remember hearing Dave on the radio say I
when things like this happen he's a
spectator
he's not participating in it because
he's risen above it financially and I
remember thinking oh my God that sounds
like the most peaceful thing that I can
think to write to not be part of the
real estate craze because in my
neighborhood we were trying to sell our
house and there were I don't know 40
other houses just like ours actually
better you know for so and just not
being able to make ends meet and I'm
listening to this guy talk about being a
spectator and I thought Am I Ever Gonna
am I ever gonna get there am I ever
gonna get that chance then 2020 happened
and I was like okay this is what it
feels like fully fund an emergency fund
even though our both both Sam and I's
job were cut off in 2020 but there's
still a feeling of peace that you can
have when you do this stuff and you you
get your money
um in order and I just I don't know if
you're listening today man you want to
be a spectator you do not want to be out
here scratching and clawing when
inflation is up you don't want to be the
people that have to take to social media
with their rage because does because
they can't sleep at night and because
they're arguing arguing with their
spouse and because they just yelled at
their daughter for asking for lunch
money yeah do you know what I'm saying
you don't want to participate in that
and the stats guys I I gotta tell you
this
this came through my email and it it it
burns me up for many reasons it burns me
up because I care about you guys I yell
at you but I care about you because I I
know what's possible but when I see
stats about savings that say 36 percent
of individuals have more credit card
debt than they have money in savings a I
get it because I've been there but it
pisses me off because you don't you
don't have to live your life like that
when I see that 10 percent have no cash
set aside when I see that 56 percent of
Americans can't handle a thousand dollar
emergency and so they go into credit
cards John and and they look to credit
cards as their savior because culture
has told us you can't exist in this
world you are not powerful enough to
handle your own money you need credit
you need debt you need to borrow in
order to make your way through life to
the tune of 930
billion dollars and hey can we can we uh
call people out right now call him out
I guarantee you
the business that I work for
makes less money
because we don't accept credit cards
here oh come on you have to spend cash
and so some of you are sitting out there
saying well I don't use credit cards I
got cash but your business accepts them
and so you are participating in the
madness and you can sit on the sidelines
on your fancy couch that so that you
paid for with somebody else's debt and
you can say look at all those stupid
idiots you are a part of the problem too
until everybody's intellectually honest
across the board those who are propping
up their lifestyle with with credit
cards and those who are accepting them
as a way to make their wardrobes nicer
while people are drowning everybody's
participating man look I saw there's
this girl I follow on Instagram and she
put on there she's like I am not she
said I sell less considerably less
because I do not do buy now pay later I
will not accept it as a form of payment
for my uh what I'm selling and I I love
that kind of Integrity because it out of
the system yeah I'm guys the average
credit card balance is almost 6 000
dollars I don't know where you come from
but where I come from that's a little
bag to have six thousand dollars extra
come on and you're wondering why don't
where's my emergency fund there it is
that's it times six that's your starter
emergency fund right there times six and
the sad part about it is most of us and
most of you probably got the credit card
to handle an emergency and now you can't
afford to fund an emergency fund because
of it that is the the sad part of it and
the serendipitous part of it now it says
delinquencies are up year over year the
credit card delinquency rate is at 2.25
now I read a stat that was saying
delinquency is not just on credit cards
but on cars we're starting to see people
get upside down on cars because we the
car payments control percent of American
consumers pay at least a thousand bucks
a month John don't tell me that a
thousand don't tell me that John a
thousand dollars on a depreciating asset
that you drive a maximum of one hour a
day that sits parked in on a piece of
concrete for 23 and a half hours a day
don't tell
help me find when your car note is a
thousand dollars
that's a lie Jay that gives me
hemorrhoid Joe that's a little excuse me
hemorrh is this preparation each time
it's six thousand dollars a month look
at this the average car payment uh
monthly car payment for new cars is
seven hundred and sixteen dollars look I
try to tell somebody look that's the
average that's the average that's the
average and I tried to tell somebody I
try to tell them and they didn't want to
listen on social media I said do you
understand that just investing not even
the whole 700 if you had 500 that you
put into good growth stock mutual funds
and you kept it there and you let it
stay for 30 years you'd have over a
million dollars but we can't
tell ourselves no for just a second for
just a second we have to say yes to the
Carno and not just any car note to the
tune of 717 dollars we do I'm here to
tell you you do not have to participate
in that there is a whole life I feel
like I feel like the beginning of Let's
Go Crazy and Prince is like dearly
beloved we are gathered here today to
talk about this thing called life a
beautiful thing called life you don't
have to participate in debt opt out you
can opt out you can you can save up your
money and you can get a thousand dollars
saved for an emergency and then you can
pay off your debt and then you can build
that up and get three to six months
saved you can still invest for
retirement you can pay for your kids
college you can pay off your house and
you can actually do this thing called
living and giving
giving John yes you can actually give
some of your money because you've been
you've been smart with your money and
you can actually share some of it
without guilt without shame without
wondering if you're going to be able to
pay your bills you can share it you can
share it with your kids their kids a
good man oh my dead leaves and my
granddad sat down and talked to me about
being a World War II vet and there's a
lot of grandparents are gonna have to
sit down and explain to their grandkids
why they just had to have a new Suburban
not in this house
that does it for this hour be sure to
join us next time when it comes to
changing your life and money remember
this you can tell me that you ain't
gonna do it but don't tell me that you
can't do it because with Christ all
things are possible if you love the show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the Ramsey Way
just go to ramseysolutions.com today to
sign up for our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build well we
help them do work that they love and we
help you create and build actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Jake warshaw
joined by the ever knowledgeable Dr John
deloney we're here taking calls about
your life and your money give us a call
the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we got Leslie in
Los Angeles California what's up with
you Leslie
hi thank you for taking my call I was
wondering is it wise to send overspend
or spend without any limits on kids
activities since we're investing in them
um I'm also asking because we kind of
overspent on the house but other than
that we are very soon wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute well I think
you're kind of answering your own
question because you said the word
overspend hold on I I gotta I gotta dig
in yeah this is my favorite Leslie I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get myself in
trouble is that okay come on John
sure when you say you're investing in
your kids what does that mean
I mean
I mean everything so now the career I
have is exactly what I want to do and I
I have a great job well what if I told
you wait can I stop you what if I told
you I had the opportunities to do almost
nothing when I was a kid and I'm in a
job that I love and I love my job
does that hit you any type of way when
you look at your kids
if you look at your kids as an Roi
proposition financially
you're going to get into a mess
you're gonna get you a message okay so
it gives people a license to I have to
send them to every sporting event all
these crazy insane travel sport nonsense
um all of the uh
not only do we have to do music lessons
we have to do all the music lessons and
by the way my kids are in music lessons
and my kids do one thing each right so
when it comes to brain development yeah
I guess you can call that an investment
when it comes to Social Development
having just having fun yes all those
things are good but if you're thinking
I'm gonna overspend right now I am going
to
make my house more anxious more chaotic
so that they can maybe one day get their
dreams that's that that math doesn't
work that's good how much are you
spending how much are you spending and
overspending
uh okay so we we spent easily up two
thousand dollars between two kids okay I
have three kids um two older kids and
then the youngest one goes to daycare
but I mean that expense you have to
spend it sure of course but the
activities for the older kids like
thousand over a thousand a month how
much debt do you have
um so we don't have any debt except for
the the house
um so we have
um uh we're spending we're paying thirty
five hundred dollars a month on our
house
um but we also took have to take out a
second loan um to buy the house because
we didn't have enough to put down
um you had to you just had to huh no we
were finally ready to buy a house and
that's when everything went crazy I know
but you know it was not ready for a
house purchase was math
math wasn't right y'all were ready but
math was what's your monthly take home
what's your take home because I want to
see what percentage
per month
yes okay so your mortgage is fine
um no no but we have more we have that
second mortgage how much is that for 10
years if that's for 10 years and it's
2600 and we owe we borrowed about a
hundred thousand dollars from a family
member and that we're uh we we're paying
them twenty five hundred dollars a month
for the next seven years so you're
paying a year you're paying 6 100 a
month for the home
to your friends
is that right uh yeah two yeah family
member yeah so 3 500 for the actual
mortgage twenty six hundred dollars for
them for ten years for the second
mortgage and twenty five hundred dollars
for seven years to a family member
Leslie you I can hear that you know that
this is insane you're paying eighty six
hundred dollars a month
to tackle all of the cares of this
mortgage
almost half of your take-home pay
yeah and then we're spending it okay
okay okay okay and you're 20 grand is
that take home or is that is that gross
that's take home okay all right all
right the good news is you've got a
great
yearly income and you've got a great
monthly income that's the good news the
bad news is you're not being a good
manager of this money
um and I I hate the what this mortgage
is doing to you the 2500 that you're
paying to your friends when is that when
does that end What's the total amount
and when is that over
um I I think it's good we have six more
years let's
um not six more years left how can you
pay it off we need to get that paid off
sooner
because you said you had no debt but
this is debt so if you said you're
paying 2500 for six years
how can we get that done faster the only
debt worse than owing a friend six
figures is IRS debt yeah so destructive
to the soul of a relationship
you owe them fifteen thousand dollars
and you make twenty thousand dollars a
month how quickly can you get them that
money
yeah
15 grand or you owe them 100 grand
no it was about a hundred thousand yeah
I don't know the exact numbers yeah so
it it is it's kind of when we did the
calculations it was about twenty five
hundred dollars for uh seven years
girl dude girl here's where this ends
this ends in Ash it ends in a huge mess
no you like I was gonna say you can't
afford to send your kids to that kind of
expense yeah you can't absolutely not
you got to clean up this this okay
you are wealthy broke people what is
this house worth
um
bought it for one
Wi-Fi
I
but you have no equity in it do you
uh we put down yeah probably
um
borrow from three different sources just
to get in the front door
yeah you guys we were supposed to buy
like a million dollar home we had 10 for
that but it just went crazy and we would
buy like nothing for a million no it
didn't go crazy you went crazy thank you
you went crazy it didn't it is just its
own thing y'all went
b-a-n-a-n-a-s here's the problem here's
a problem Leslie and and and I I gotta
get I gotta get in my my jade stance
here for a minute because
you've got it you've got to you've got
to start with the man in the mirror you
gotta look at this and go I and my
husband did every part of this the
market didn't just happen something
didn't just up and happen to you you
went along for the ride and you signed
up for it and you were like hey we'll do
this hey you called in the show and said
I'm overspending which means you know
that you're doing it but you're still
trying to find this external thing to
blame for or say that it's okay you're
if you don't start changing your habits
and changing them quick you're going to
be up you're already up a creek without
a paddle you guys Gotta Get This Money
paid off you make two money too much
money to be this broke if a bank won't
loan you money
if they won't do it then something's up
sums up because a bank will give money
they will lend money they will give
money to a pet dope they'll issue a loan
for a dead person the bank if the bank
won't do it you ain't got no business
getting it
I feel for you Leslie this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw your host joined by my
co-host John deloney and we're taking
calls about your life your money your
relationships whatever's going on with
your money situation we want to talk
about it if something fishy is going on
with your job we want to talk about it
something weird is going on at home with
your money and your spouse we want to
talk about that give us a call the the
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five we got Allison in
Portland Oregon oh that's my old neck of
the woods what's going on Allison
nothing much I guess
um I'm having some problems with my
spouse uh I budget he doesn't budget I
talk about my debt he doesn't talk about
his debt so I'm just wondering how to
bring that conversation up to him and
kind of get somewhere with it
tell me a little bit more the way you're
framing that sounds like you're talking
about a roommate or a business partner
not your husband
right now when it goes
it goes we have access to like debit
accounts but credit like he has access
to my credit cards if he wants to look I
have no idea what happens with his
credit card
um it seems like at the end of the month
he's left with a little to no money in
his account
and
I'm left with I mean I'm I've started
saving for a house I've started saving
for you know emergency funds things like
that but it doesn't he hasn't been
chipping in how long have you been
married
uh since September two years two years
um one of two things is happening
either he is seeing somebody else
or struggling with
um an addiction of some sort
or has not left behind his former life
that he had before he stood before
friends and family and God and said
um I do
he's propping up a lifestyle
at your expense
or he is such a huge debt mess
and the shame surrounding that is so big
he's trying to do everything he can to
hide it from you
okay and I I
don't like as your friend just you and I
just having nachos hanging out I don't
believe you that this is everything else
in your marriage is great except for
money
that never is the case what else does he
not talk to you about
this like I wouldn't be able to tell you
I feel like we talk about every any
everything except
talking about it hasn't been brought up
to me
do you think that it's more of the
latter that it's some sort of debt mess
that he has and he doesn't I think I
think there's some shame around I mean I
make more money than him how much more
uh
40 Grand more okay can you just tell me
the the full number that you make and
the full number that he makes
so I make about
90 okay a year okay he makes about 45.
is he insecure about that
I think so but like it's not a
conversation that I've been able to have
he doesn't like to have that
conversation so I think that's part of
it so I'm like hey you know I've saved
up this much for a house
and you have no doubt I don't want to
have that have no I do have debt and I'm
still paying off my debt but I make so
if you if you had been my sister or my
daughter
I would have told you to have this
conversation before you get married and
if the person you're about to marry
won't talk to you about money and won't
combine accounts with you and won't
partner with you on a life together but
wants to is just hell-bent on having two
parallel lives together I would say
absolutely under no circumstances should
you get married zero
yeah couples that don't have this
discussion end up in Ash always
and when you bring kids into the mix it
gets magnified when you put home
ownership in the mix it gets magnified
because just the way you're talking
you're not talking like married people
you're talking like next door neighbors
his money my money and his account and
my account that's not married talk
that is two people who are playing house
talk
and I'm not saying that to shame you I'm
saying that I'm heartbroken for you that
this is where you found yourself
and I'm heartbroken that you think so
little of your safety you don't feel
safe in this house because you don't
even know where you stand
and you thought you were marrying a
partner and you married a child and
you're
yeah
the only way this thing turns around is
if you sit down and say I'm not going
another step until we have this money
conversation
now question Allison I have a question
for you if you okay aside from sharing
accounts getting his password things
like that if you just say to him hey I
just want to talk about our beliefs like
what do you believe about debt what do
you believe about like is he willing to
have any Stitch of a conversation with
you or is it just simply and if you ask
them hey
is it is it just a total brick wall or
is it like hey I just don't feel
comfortable sharing my like on a scale
of one to ten I want to know how
Ironclad this is
I would say if we like sit down and have
a like I can bring stuff up about it and
he'll answer but the answer is very
vague so if I was like hey this is my
goal like for you know my five-year goal
my three year goal whatever it might be
he's he's very supportive of it he'll be
like okay like I understand that that's
kind of something I want to do they'll
be like oh so how do you plan to do it
and that's where it kind of shuts off
okay and if you were to say Hey you have
debt how much he'd just be like yeah I
have debt but he's not going to give you
a ballpark
yeah like I know there's some student
loans I know there's credit cards that's
what I know I don't know if they end
like a loan or anything else he doesn't
have a cart payment anything like that
here's what I want to ask and I'm asking
John on your behalf because I've seen
this before
um
is it just a sense of control like is it
because some people just like to Lord
over finances and they just like to
control it and and it's just their thing
you're not gonna tell me what to do this
is my thing I make my mind and it's just
a control thing yeah well that's that's
it becomes about power right this is my
life I can do whatever I want to and by
the way I can control your life yeah and
or number two it's about Shane
right it's it's I've dug myself a hole
I'm in a mess my wife makes twice as
much money and then I it you know right
it becomes this whole faulty narrative
but listen I I was getting on to him
Allison but when you sit down and you
tell your husband here's my five-year
goals
he has what's he gonna tell you no you
can't do those things if if he loves you
he's going to say great you've got to
stop having these mine and yours you got
to start having our conversations yeah
that's a big Point
um Allison when I got married to Sam he
had
pharah in the majority of student loans
that I had he had about 230 and I had
about 34. and so the conversations about
money it was like an onion it was like
all right in this conversation I get
this layer and then the next
conversation I'm discovering something
else and then and over time he was
sharing more and more
um the source of that was a lot a lot of
Shame a lot of regret a lot of hey I'm
holding you back in your life like if it
wasn't for this we could be doing like
that was the source of it and the best
thing that I was able to do is every
time we had those conversations I was
just like thanks for telling me like
let's let's do more like and and I
actually started getting mad at him
um and saying like what do you not trust
me do you not think I'm gonna support
you through this you know like what I
kind of started posing the question to
him like you not telling me is telling
you something telling me something about
the character you believe I have if you
believe that I'm not a ride or die if
you believe that I'm not going to stand
with you through this is that what you
think so I kind of started you know
putting it putting it to him like that
and and the more that I showed him hey
like I'm in this is our money it's our
debt the more we are able to speak
openly about it until all of that came
out and the more that I was like hey
your debt is my debt and I don't know
the ins and outs of your situation but I
can only tell you my own experience and
as much as you like what John said man
rehab that vocab and start saying we and
I and this is the life that I that that
we can build together and what we can do
with our money and here's our dreams and
that sort of thing man that can that can
tear down walls so here's what this
looks like Allison this looks like you
and him
um inviting him out for a breakfast and
I like breakfast just because sometimes
these conversations can take two or
three or four hours a lot of twists and
turns but invite them out for a
breakfast and say we need to have a hard
two-year a conversation two-year
check-in and when you sit down and say
I'm scared to death and I can't breathe
because I don't know where we are
financially we're living two separate
lives
we need to create our future not mine
and yours but our future that starts
with you being honest about what we owe
what our debts are and how we are going
to create a new life
but it starts with you admitting I'm
terrified will you please help me
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on guys it's the Ramsey
Show I'm your host Jade warshaw joined
by Dr John deloney taking calls today
your life your money how to build wealth
how to budget how to get out of this
thing called inflation and Rise Above
whatever it is we're taking your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five
when John was the last time that you
were excited about a Monday I'm always
excited about Mondays I kind of I kind
of am too but if if if that's you if
you're struggling What If instead of
waking up exhausted you felt exhilarated
you can't wait to get to work because
it's another day to fulfill your passion
all right in a world where the bare
minimum Monday I hate that phrase a
trend has taken place of quiet quitting
it's clear people are craving meaningful
work but finding the career you were
born to do can be difficult when you
don't have the right tools that's why
career expert and Ramsay personality my
dog Ken Coleman created the get clear
career assessment to help you discover
your top talents passions and a clear
mission statement that'll help you find
work that the work that the world needs
you to do I love that the world needs
you you've got something inside you that
the world needs and after taking this
quick assessment you'll get a custom
Report with everything you need to take
the first step towards a meaningful
career start your journey and take the
get clear assessment today all you need
to do do is go to ramseysolutions.com
get clear and I can tell you man the
road to finding what you were meant to
do man it can be for me it was a little
bit of a it was a windy road John I'm
still trying to figure it out man I
somehow stumbled into being a YouTuber
can you believe it I don't know how long
this is gonna last but I mean I know me
a lot of what we did to find our path
was so driven by like that Financial
survival yeah that that that Journey
getting out of debt and it was all like
a blur it's like you get out of college
and I had a music degree and it was like
what what the heck am I supposed to do
with a music degree nobody's ever asked
to see my degree ever and it's like
you're just trying to trying to make
your way out in the world and uh that
kind of brings me it brings me to my
next segment John they want us to talk
about
some of the craziest things we've ever
done to get money
weirdest money stories am I saying that
right yeah bro Austin like the statute
of limitations hadn't run out on some of
these things man I can't be saying that
there's warrants there's warrants out
what's the matter with you I can't say
some of this I've never done anything
illegal to get money like that I know
well thanks for kicking me while yeah
I'm sorry I was playing um all my
stories are funny stories they're not
like involving the popos I mean I I yeah
I I
I would do things like I was the
associate dean of a college and then on
on Saturday and Sunday I was painting
dorm rooms and
um like
I was doing things in the morning and
delivering things in the evening I was
all over the place man uh yeah I don't
know I
I've had I can tell you some jobs Sam is
like in the lobby motioning something to
me I'm like I don't know what you're
talking about but I can tell you the
craziest story that Sam and I had is
okay so we owed lots of money half a
million and uh we were trying to get
money
um I had an audition that I needed to do
and we needed to be able to move and so
Sam was like hey we had run out of
things to sell we had literally sold
everything in the house like to the
point that we had no furniture like
people would come over and be just
sitting on the staircase because we had
no furniture so Sam gets this bright
idea he's like hey I know what we can
sell to get money and I'm like what he
goes I loaned my friend a keyboard back
in high school
and I'm like think in my head I'm
thinking it's like like this is back in
like the early 2000s something and it's
like a Triton like a like one of those
nice keyboards and so he goes I'm gonna
call him up and see if he still has it
I'm like okay so he calls up Andrew and
Andrew's like dude I don't know if I
still have this you're a bad guy Sam
he's like man he's like you can search
you can search the garage and see if you
can find it so we drive over to his
house by the way he lives with his
parents in like this giant mansion we
get to the house and Andrew's like dude
check the garage so he opens up he's my
husband is like searching in the garage
for this keyboard he finally finds it
and it's like an old like Walmart Casio
bro I was like what are we gonna get for
this is 20 20 but that's when let me
tell you when you're out here man
you will go for it you will go do in
when I tell you so when I tell y'all to
go sell stuff and when I tell you guys
to get crazy that I know I'm not telling
you to do anything I didn't do I rented
a room out of my buddy's mom's house
like stayed in I mean I was a grown man
with a with a good job
uh I was engaged and I was waiting to
get married and I lived in a house yeah
we sold our house we sold our nice house
and moved into a dorm we do some crazy
stuff to try to make make ends meet
but did you sleep on an air mattress for
five years I did not do that I slept on
an air mattress for five years and I'm
checking my text because
I was like one oh
next to me the craziest thing we ever
did for money I forgot about this we
used to work on cruise lines okay and we
used to get booked to do our show on the
cruise lines and so we got booked John
to do a nude Cruise
all the passengers
passengers on the ship were buck naked
and I had to perform with my clothes on
I did not participate in this craziness
we performed we were on the ship for
five days
with all naked people oh wow 3 000 naked
people John that's the craziest thing
I've ever done to get money the craziest
thing
I'm you're talking about somebody in the
buffet
no slicing some ham no no sandwich yes
America can we be better than that no
naked Buffet I'm telling you I went to
the gym and your boy was on that leg
press he was getting it on the like
Prince no
no
this is a true story true story I forgot
about it thank you Sam for texting me
that man
that's it John all right you win you win
you win when I tell y'all we did some
things I'm telling you we did some
things all right with that we need to
take a call we need to get our lives
back together we got Reyna in Houston
Texas what's going on right what's up
Rayna
hello
um I was just calling because
um I just started the Dave Ramsey plan
and
um prior to this I used to be really
really poor so every time I would get my
income tax I would um just put it
towards my rent
um I have a house now and um I owe 46
950 dollars and what I used to do was
pay our bills in advance so I'm not due
till September 1st on my mortgage and I
have a car payment
that I'm not due till July
and it's 6 52 but and I have a
401k loan for 7 000.
which is next in line to get paid I have
a thousand dollar emergency fund and my
question is is
do I just continue to pay my bills as if
I'm not ahead or do I just not pay it to
those dates and just put that towards
this the the 401K loan like I'm not sure
what direction to go into
random Jade's gonna walk you through it
I just want to tell you I'm so so proud
of you
thank you no like listen I call thank
you what you have done
is some of the hardest work a human can
do you you took a machete and you head
off into the woods and you said there is
no Trail I will make one
and that makes you strong and it makes
you Brave and uh it's an honor to to
have gotten get to talk to you
it's awesome
okay I'm sorry I'm I'm so proud of you
it's amazing
fellow houstonian here I'm so proud of
you it's amazing all right go ahead Jade
I think you're doing great you know that
the fact that you're getting ahead
that's letting me know that you've got
extra money in your budget to do that I
feel like you're still kind of in that
survival mode and I want you to know
that you don't have to operate like that
you can do a month-to-month budget like
everybody else and I think that you're
going to get further faster that way
because you're really going to see the
margin that you have to start paying
down uh this this 401k loan to start
paying your car completely off so I want
you to walk the baby steps um you've got
the thousand dollars saved that's an
excellent job and I want you to work
your baby step two which is paying off
your debt and I want you to use the debt
snowball method so Reina with that
you're listing all of your debt from
smallest to largest so you mentioned a
car note you mentioned a 401k loan if
there's anything else in that list that
debt from smallest to largest make
minimum payments on all of the debt and
put any and all extra money on the
smallest debt until it's gone and work
that snowball until all your debts are
gone and then you're going to be able to
stack up a nice three to six month
emergency fund to finish this out for
you and then go go on through the baby
steps you're going to be investing
you're going to be saving for kids
college you are doing a fabulous job
you're going to be one of these people
standing on this stage as a baby steps
millionaire one day hey let's get out of
FPU for a year and let's get her every
dollar
um just so we can support her on her
amazing transformation this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
your host Jade warshaw joined by Dr John
deloney taking calls about your life and
your money
scripture and quote of the day Proverbs
18 22 says this by your endurance you
will gain your lives
let that one sink in like it AC DC Come
On Son It's a Long Way to the Top If you
want to rock and roll I feel like they
did that for you John I'll take it maybe
they did it for me too it's a Long Way
to the Top If you want to rock it I
don't know usually when you have an AC
DC quote next to a Bible verse the paper
just catches fire but whatever guys it
did catch fire earlier I put it out
already
we're taking your calls give us a call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five we got Ryan in Indianapolis Indiana
what's going down
hey guys thanks for taking my call of
course but my question is my wife and I
are 27 and 26
um we're in baby steps 3B slash four
kind of in the house saving slash
investing 15
Steps we are wondering if we should
leave our family and kind of like
everything we have behind in our small
rural Indiana town
for a government job kind of across the
country whether that be in Texas North
Carolina
um for and of course the benefits that
come with that you know housing stock
and pension
um why would you not do this
so the only thing holding us back is our
family do you even like them
we love our family yes that's good
that's the hard part
we love our families and we've moved
across the country for work and for
opportunity and I don't know I can't
speak for you guys but it's been great I
think it's been yeah
I'm not going to say that it's always
easy because it's hard Community I mean
you can't buy Community you cannot you
know that's one of those things it takes
time digging in and creating and what
you've created over time in Indianapolis
that's not going to just crop up for you
you know like six months into it or a
year into it that takes time to build so
I'm not gonna lie to you and say it's
going to be easy but you've got to sit
down with your wife and kind of
sort through like what what are what do
we want and what does that look like and
what are we willing to sacrifice because
they're you got to take the the bad with
the good
yeah so like would you actually just
renting a course in the beginning so we
have about 60 Grand saved up for a house
absolutely rent absolutely
yes because you and you get two
variables here one you don't know that
you don't know the ins and outs of the
community you're going to be landing in
and so you don't want to buy a house and
then realize you wish you were on the
other side of town or you wish you were
more rural or more downtown or whatever
and two you don't know if this is
here's here's what a lot of folks boxed
himself in especially as 26 and 27 year
olds it's either we stay here forever
and die or we move and we never come
back and those that's a false binary
narrative it's not true you can move for
18 months you can move for six months
and both you and your wife look at each
other and say that this is a disaster we
got to go back and in a small rural Town
two awesome folks like you they'll take
you back they sure will or you can move
and realize ah and when you don't have a
house payment you're renting the pr
there's no pressure sitting on on you on
your chest and on your wife's chest you
can't breathe and then you can actually
live your life and decide is this is
this for us or not when me and my wife
moved from Nashville to I mean from
Texas Nashville we rented we rented for
a couple years that's such a good point
Ryan and and Sam and I did the same
thing when we were making the decision
to come here to Nashville one of the
things that gave me so much peace is I
was like if we hate it we can go back we
just leave like we're we're adults like
no one's gonna stop us and so I think
that yeah I I think it's exciting yet
again we talked to somebody who has done
well with their money they've got
choices that they can make and there's
not a right or wrong choice you can just
up and decide what do you want to do
they got options I love that thanks for
the call Ryan it's up to you what you
want to do it's up to you and your
family you can do either one all right
we got Ryan in Lansing Michigan what's
going on Matthew I gotta put my glasses
on John what's going on Matthew how can
we help
hey uh uh I'm doing well I just I'm a
new listener to the podcast been
listening for a month or so welcome to
the game 18 years old and uh I currently
am working for state government
and I really don't like my job but
they're paying for a lot of my college
um so my question to you is should I
leave my job because I don't like it and
then have to pay more for college or
should I stick with this job for a few
more years and get the college paid for
it how old are you
18. what are you going to college for
uh cyber security
is are you enjoying your coursework is
that what you want to do
uh yeah I it's it's not necessarily my
dream job but it is
um probably the what I would want to do
that's actually going to pay the bills
okay
I if I'm you I would tell you to just to
stay and get your job should keep keep
your work and get your college paid for
you're good and here's why because
you're 18.
um like if you quit you're gonna go to
college and you're gonna be waiting
tables and mowing lawn I mean you're
going to be doing work
um on the side to make these payments
and so I would say man get all the
experience you can see if you can get
involved in some of the I.T work or some
of the cyber security work or go to
coffee with those guys so it may not be
the ins and outs of your job but you
don't that you love every day but do you
what you can like Ken talks about what
the proximity principle to rub shoulders
with some of these folks in the security
work or the government work how it all
works none of that's going to go to
waste because I can see you getting done
with your uh four-year degree getting a
certificate in cyber security and then
having four years of government work on
your resume and that's going to look
real good
okay and and with that
um it is possible for me to to transfer
um within the government to other
positions
um would you recommend me look into that
as well why wouldn't you
I don't know I just I'm not sure if if
that would leave like I've only been at
the job I'm at for for six months and I
don't want what about it do you not live
for that what about it do you not like
the job yeah
uh it's very mundane work um I don't
feel like I'm really accomplishing
anything and then at the same time uh
there's very few achievable goals I
don't have uh there's not a set uh
I guess completion of a task it's just
kind of work on it and it never really
gets done you know
yeah I I guess what I'm asking is
um
you're and Jade hop in here you're
you're currently seeking a degree
to get qualified for the job that you
want to do
and so you are not at this current job
for any philosophical reason other than
they provide you an experience and a
paycheck
and that paycheck is being used to fund
your qualifying
um your your qualification path so that
you can get this this job you want when
you we are expecting and all of us do
this but we we've created a culture
where we expect our jobs to give us all
of our purpose and all of our meaning
and all of our all and sometimes it's a
means to an end and right now you've got
you've got a you've got a date that a
Finish Line here and that's graduation
and then you're done right I agree it's
a means to an end like you said if you
were older and and you were calling in
just saying hey I hate my job I need to
get out of it that's different but
you're young you're using this to pay
for your education you're trading one
thing for another I think it's a great
trade because you're getting your school
paid for yeah you're not going to have
student loans coming out of this now I
think that that's worth it
um if there's some reason that you get
out of this then you just gotta swear to
yourself that you're gonna pay cash from
here on out that's that's really where
the the give and take of this if you're
not going to keep this job how are you
going to pay for school I actually
um this is me I
I like that you you need to sit in a
mundane boring job for a season man to
show yourself I can do this I can do I
can do tough stuff I can do boring stuff
I can do exhausting stuff there's a
there's a there's a
strength and character on the back end
of this
um that I think would be worth your time
and as an 18 year old you're rolling
your eyes right now I can feel them
through the phone you're like oh gosh
this old idiot I get that that's fine
but raise your hand if you've ever
worked a job that you hated exactly I
mean come on everybody everybody and and
especially when it's a means to an end
so yeah um if if you have an opportunity
to move or move in there and find
something that's more you think
absolutely but I wouldn't go applying
and saying I'm through with this
terrible I'd ride it out man you've got
a pretty sweet set up right now and it's
it's adjacent to what you want to do for
your for your career I I let it ride
brother and take the free tuition
do the same thing look there's purpose
in the process and a lot of times we
want to try to get skirt that process
because it's not fun or it's boring or
it's not what all that it was cracked up
to be but in this case it's serving a
greater purpose all right that does it
for this hour be sure to join us next
time and remember when it comes to
changing your life and your money you
can tell me that you won't do it but
please don't tell me you can't do it
with Christ all things are possible
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]